well
hello how are you health andrés gonzález
with informative hat for today
wednesday october 20 a protest
began wednesday morning at the
g20 clark county workers in the
family services part someone
who wants better
working conditions county officials said
in  A statement that by Kobe they were
forced to pause hiring
employees for almost a year they said that they
are already in the process after interviewing
several candidates and their focus is to
hire more
mental health professionals
the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
is still in  following the clues of the
suspects in the shooting that occurred on
the highway on monday morning this
happened in a sector of the airport and
friday sprints the family identified
the victim as 25-year-old glencore a
man with three children a woman who was a
passenger was found  seriously injured
the authorities are looking for a
gray four-door
vehicle  Vegas' Rulers prepare for
another home game for the third of the
regular season after beating them to be
opted out in their debut in the win-out game on
October 12, but the
Bikinis come off a road loss in
Los Angeles on October 14.  October with a
score of 6 to 2 tonight they will
face each other Monday starting at
7 with nights go
and now we go to see the weather forecast
we will have some breezes for today
reaching a maximum of 75 degrees in
the afternoon this weekend the temperatures will rise
temperatures up to 80 we will continue with
a pleasant climate for the next
week 3 gonzález happen and this was
about the hilux nao news in
Spanish good day
[Music]